can I future rats I'll give a dollar
okay got some juice right here so I'm
good too so can he pee on it no let's do
so just put the cups aluminum you guys
are really cute for do these yours like
did you get them are your five essence
of hands in newer 60 do you guys want
treats come here I want to feed all they
are they not have any other kind create
any change you whisper that's all I had
I had a dollar and one of the other
people are all yeah yeah they're
probably do pop yet sweet see we love
you God waiting near real I don't think
I have any sweet sweet i do have sweets
good there you go oh you know I
hey do I bought this Japanese candy
should I oh is that okay for them yeah
gonna eat that can you guys see the
Japanese candy it's Japanese you guys
don't like it that's all I guy but
you're cute though so well they are you
go stop bein done so we can be it all
for you guys you guys enjoy your treats
okay